the nature of forensic French
institutions themselves is in disarray
no one can really decide who's owning
this agenda and who's supposed to be
delivering that influence countering
myths and disinformation and I think
ultimately France lacks a game plan I
think this actually creates an extremely
unpredictable and potentially dangerous
situation not just for francophony but
for key British allies in Africa not
least Ghana not least Nigeria so all of
a sudden I think all the littoral West
Africa parts of central Africa and parts
of North Africa are now in play for
Global power competition journalism
makes a very good point there because
there is a sense in which this could
become contagious and France's position
as an international power could be
seriously undermined and that would have
an impact not just on France of course
but also on the west and on Britain in
particular